there is a challenge online where there
are dogs that are holding eggs in their
mouth like their mouths are so soft and
there are such sweet puppies that they
will hold an egg without breaking it
basically you're challenging your dog to
hold a raw egg to see if they have a
gentle mouth so then you start seeing a
lot of golden retrievers doing the same
challenge and passing it but then a
bunch of other dog breeds are doing it
there are a lot of gentle pups out there
are you wanna go alright Lucy we're
gonna try this this is an egg you taking
your mouth she's just looking it okay
open your mouth oh no you're not gonna
do it okay maybe we need to practice
with something else get the lemon oh no
you're gonna pick it ready open your
mouth no keep me gentle and pick it up
no don't bite no it's not gonna happen
obviously my dog's not gonna be the one
that's gonna be picking up an egg any
time soon
Lucy why are certain dogs able to do
this it doesn't really mean that they're
just like a nicer more dental dogs a lot
of dogs fail it so what I know why Lucy
can't do it while all these other dogs
can so I decided to sit down with a
veterinarian to find out what's going on
with this egg challenge and what does it
really mean the egg challenge is owners
trying to find out if their dogs are
capable of holding eggs in their mouths
without breaking them it started with
golden retrievers this they have what's
called a soft mouth
golden retrievers are amazing or that's
like what made me become a vet they are
just known to be gentle dogs your
structure should determine your
functions and you just look at the
structure of their body their mouths are
kind of shaped in what we call it dhola
cephalic it's basically in an elongated
mouth so it's bigger and longer and it's
more capable I guess of holding eggs
there are so many in terms of all these
different types of dogs being able to do
it
how you look is gonna determine whether
you're a gentle personality or not I
think a pit bull could totally do that
they're super devil but if your dog
can't do this dog can be the gentlest
most amazing dog ever and still not be
able to hold an egg in her mouth they
might not be as intelligent perhaps it
might be a matter just general training
I could train yeah there's new potential
for anything don't worry I just don't
want you to call my dog stupid because I
want to prove that she is a smart puppy
and also gentle I want to try the egg
challenge again with Lucy I have to
sanitize the egg because Salmonella can
live outside or inside bag I've seen
videos and owner washing the egg three
seconds under running water yeah I don't
know if that would do anything if you
put poop under running water it's
probably still dirty this is what will
get me the most likes on Instagram
mm-hmm I'm gonna wash it with soap
before giving it to my dog so I'm gonna
keeping it with sanitizer and rinse it
off I've got a sanitized day okay and
now we're gonna try it on Lucy cake hey
morning take this isn't gonna help Lucy
do you want to try you're holding the
egg I don't think she wants to do this
anymore I've been having a lot of
trouble it's not because she's stupid
it's because I'm stupid and I'm bad at
training do you want it oh I don't need
to prove that Lucy's a gentle and smart
dog because I know he is but I'm going
to prove that I'm smart enough to teach
her to do the egg challenge won't you
take my own so training is not going so
well
she's like frenemies with egg right now
and I need to make her just friends
start with treats I feel like if they
can't do it with a treat they probably
can't do it with an egg so see if they
can just hold a treat without eating it
mm-hmm breading doggie peanut butter on
the egg Lucy you interested in a now
you're gonna lick it
don't you want pick up the egg okay once
he takes the edge you just licked the
peanut butter so my plan didn't work
she's avoiding me and hiding in her
doggie tepee new strategy I am going to
try to get her use to the egg you feel
better oh the eggy so we're getting
close
shake it and hold it you put down right
away
you did it kind of Lucy is now able to
hold the egg but she drops it right away
Oh Lucy getting the dog to hold it as
one thing and to keep it in their mouth
is another probably cuz she doesn't want
an egg in her mouth because who would
want an egg in their mouth called it oh
okay alright we're getting close
tape we finally got Lucy to pass the egg
challenge like barely sheared a sound
outside and got distracted so she got
too distracted to drop it I'm proud of
you you actually did the egg challenge
you know why Lucy's not good at the egg
challenge and she's dropping it it's
because she's doing it on purpose
because she's smart and we know Lucy
likes to play basketball so we're gonna
see Lucy can basketball with the egg she
can win her own challenges take it
basket
[Music]
alright Lucy just whoa that's right
maybe she couldn't quite pass the egg
challenge but she getting nailed the egg
basket challenge look how perfectly that
split in half I so can't believe it
we're gonna celebrate like give him Lucy
some eggs because she deserves it
because she cracked it and she's so
smart
and I'm so good at dreaming take that
bet